[Music]
they are a several news about the Star
Wars franchise this week for one part
the extremely popular Disney Plus here
is the Mandalorian surprises with a new
character for the second season this
character will be in line with
appearance of ahsoka tano who was
announced a few weeks ago and will also
be included in this series soon the
character in question is a bucket on
cara's who will be played by actress
Katee Sackhoff folketing Christ will
probably be best known to fans of Star
Wars of the Clone Wars and Star Wars
rebels in both animation series the
Mandalorian warrior has turned into a
real fan favorite and is now even
brought to life by her longtime dubbing
voice Katee Sackhoff which role volca
town is going to play in the second
season of the Mandalorians unfortunately
not yet known but will surely be
announced soon fans of the Mandalorian
can also look forward to another new
addition because as The Hollywood
Reporter reports bounty hunter Boba Fett
will also be part of the second season
him where a Morrison will take over the
role of the aging Boba Fett by the way
you can watch the second season of the
Mandalorian on Disney Plus from October
2020 on since the start date is
fortunately not affected by the pandemic
is Disney CEO Bob Chaput confirmed a few
days ago it is also officially confirmed
that Taika Waititi will direct the
upcoming Star Wars movie the successful
director was already allowed to try his
skills with the finale of the
mandalorian season 1 and is now supposed
to show what he can do with the expected
movie and not only in the director's
chair because YTD also works together
with screenwriter Christie Wilson
Karen's on the script of the movie
information about the upcoming film is
still scarce as currently the only
official confirmed start dates are
December 16th 2020 to December 20th 2024
and December 18 2026 is still unclear
which of the days ytt will get but we
can but we can probably expect news soon
as the Star Wars Celebration announced
for the end of August will take place
despite possible restrictions already
some time ago 20th Century Fox announced
that x-men new mutants will get a new
star date for the cinema due to the
pandemic as you can see now on a new
poster of the movie the new release date
is already this summer on August 28th
2020 which is only the u.s. state at
least now realistic date has finally
been set
because the release date which was
originally planned for 2018 has already
been changed and postponed several times
the story revolves around a group of
young mutants who meet in a remote
hospital together they try to find out
more about the greedy operators because
it seems they are only interested in the
superpowers of the mutants
well they succeed or not you can find
out from the end of August and cinemas
since the release of Deadpool in 2016
everyone is talking about the antihero
when a second part was released in 2018
and it could even tie up to the
box-office success of the first part the
question of the third part was more or
less decided but what followed was the
Fox takeover by Disney and with it the
great uncertainty whether wait Wilson's
course humor is not in contradiction to
Disney's family-friendly image until the
very end there was great hope that
Disney due to the immense of success
would overcome itself and commissioned a
third part but this discussion is
probably on hold for the time being
since Deadpool created roughly felt
recently in an interview with inverse
did not predict a rosy future for the
mercenary in the red and black garb
according to his statements this is
probably the end of the film series
because Marvel boss Kevin Feige is still
not interested in a Deadpool sequel he
himself was realistic enough to accept
that the franchise is now at an end
after two very successful films he also
stressed once again that he simply can't
imagine a continuation with Marvel many
fans are now wondering while leading
actor Ryan Reynolds announced last
December that Marvel had given the
greenlight for Deadpool 3 which
naturally raises the question as to
which of the two is really right
roughly failed as the creator of
Deadpool is of course involved in the
development process but it seems as if
Reynolds as the main actor is naturally
more directly involved in the actual
production the fact that his statement
was made much longer ago than that of
Rob Liefeld speaks of course against
this what do you think is Disney still
working on Deadpool 3 in the background
or deadly felt actually announced the
end of the series with his comment write
your opinion in the comments in an
interview with Empire magazine avatar
director James Cameron had few nice
things to say about the shooting as the
restrictions and delays made the
production of the film extremely
difficult on top of that is a break of
meanwhile more than 10 years between the
first and the second part and to make
things worse
there are also constant postponement of
the movies
but further postponement could now be a
thing of the past at least for the time
being because in the recent interview
with Empire he's optimistic about the
future he assumes that the shooting will
be delayed for a few more months but
then it can be continued as planned
that's to be hoped because with the
gigantic project avatar Cameron has a
lot of plans for the future since 2017
the shooting of the four sequels has
been in progress and the amount of work
behind the scenes hasn't decreased since
the first part so it's to be hoped that
Cameron will soon be able to continue
shooting again so the cinema release on
December 17th 2021 will not be
jeopardized even more for some years now
Disney has been following this sometimes
more sometimes less successful recipe of
re-releasing old classics as live-action
versions the latest film of this kind
Mulan was recently postponed to the
current situation in the past they have
also been several reports about working
on live-action Robin Hood or Hercules
and as some sources now report the
Disney machinery is already working on
the next remake rumors say that Atlantis
the lost Empire is supposed to be next
the original film by Gary Trousdale and
Kirk wise was released in 2001 and asked
one of the few Disney animated films
without musical elements it brought in
186 million u.s. dollars worldwide
Atlantis is now one of the Disney
classics and no animation film
collection can be imagined without it
partly because of its unique animations
based on the style of Hellboy creator
Mike manilla when we can expect the
live-action filming is unfortunately not
known yet the heir of Iron Man aka Tony
Stark has been over since Avengers and
came also return of Robert Downey jr. as
Iron Man in the MCU is rather unlikely
but a possible successor of a somewhat
different kind is already in the making
the insider Thomas politi of the cinema
spot claims to have found out that
Disney Plus is currently actively
working on a series about super heroine
RiRi Williams that's pretty conclusive
because at least in the comics she will
later fall in the footsteps of Iron Man
according to police information that
Marvel is currently looking for a
suitable showrunner to start filming
next year of course this information
should be treated with caution at the
moment because although Polito has a
very reliable reputation in the scene
there's still no official news from
Disney
ever if he's right and release in late
2022 or early 2023 would be quite
realistic on October 29th 2020 Snake
Eyes GI Joe origins is expected to be a
new film that'll boost the franchise
again the German director Robert
Schwentke will be shooting a story about
an elitist killer clam that only takes
on the most dangerous of assignments and
thus aroused the interest of snake eyes
this is a spin-off of the series which
is supposed to bring in some momentum
after the last two not really successful
films as The Hollywood Reporter now
reports producer Lorenzo di Bonaventura
has now received the order for another
GI Joe movie allegedly negotiations with
the screenwriters Joe shrapnel and Anna
Waterhouse are still ongoing the new
film is not supposed to be classic
sequel to snake eyes despite its context
instead they want to tackle a further
expansion of the universe and let the
audience dive deeper into the world of
GI Joe snake eyes GI Joe origins will be
released in the US on October 23rd 2020
but release date for the second film is
not yet known
[Music]